What's up guys!
We are Pongfinity
Today we are trying out wheelchair table tennis!
Feels quite good
It's easy if you play to one spot
I didn't see that coming!
We had a session with our friend Aino Tapola
Who is one of the world's best wheelchair table tennis players in her class (1)
She showed us some of the main tactics and shots in wheelchair table tennis
And now we are going to try them out!
In wheelchair table tennis
The serve isn't allowed to come off the side of the table
So the best serves are:
A really short one
Or a long fast one
No, you see that's not a very good serve!
No, it's not so good!
The best shot in wheelchair table tennis
Is a short backspin that returns to your own side
It's very difficult for the opponent to reach
Yes, I got it!
Okay let's try playing some points against Aino
Let's see how it goes!
I just got the one in the corner
It's so tactically different
It was easier against you Emil!
I'm wrong way around now...
Even in wheelchair table tennis I'm doing a lot of extra movement
Too slow!
Impossible
Yeah that was good
Hope you guys found this video interesting
And let us know in the comments below
If you want to see a Pongfinity wheelchair tournament
Until next time!